new in theaters this weekend once upon a
time in Hollywood what will you see this
is your weekend ticket
[Music]
Rick Dalton it's my pleasure
then mr. Schwartz I'll be mouthing put
it down bet your son no that's my stunt
double cliff booth hey Rick Dalton
double feature I love that stuff you're
told that killing a lot of killing
Quentin Tarantino's ninth film once upon
a time in Hollywood hits the silver
screen this weekend the film takes place
at the end of the Golden Age of 1969
Hollywood as actor Rick Dalton played by
Leonardo DiCaprio and his stunt double
played by Brad Pitt deal with the
changes happening in the evolving movie
and TV industry and the fear of becoming
a fading star I hired you to be an actor
week TV cowboy blonde film also stars
Margot Robbie as Sharon Tate as well as
a huge impressive cast like her Russell
Al Pacino Dakota Fanning Luke Perry and
Timothy olefin my god that's a lot of
beautiful people Here I am flat on my
ass I got a little next door to me I'm
Sharon Tate I play Miss Carlson clubs
[Music]
can you look where you going
[Music]
Charlie's gonna take you
the fill is already getting rave reviews
and has a 92% on the tomato meter as of
this filming so it looks like we've got
another Quentin Tarantino classic on our
hands my hands are registered as lethal
weapons we get into a fight I
accidentally kill you I go to jail
anybody accidentally kills anybody in
fight they go to jail
it's called manslaughter this movie is
for you if you're a fan of Quentin
Tarantino's work you're excited to see
the buddy-style chemistry between
Leonardo DiCaprio and Brad Pitt or you
like watching actors take on the
difficult challenge of playing actors I
mean I could never play a host on an
Internet show that weekend is your
ticket nope I can't it's too difficult
that is your weekend ticket will you see
and check back next week for a fantastic
Fast and the Furious fix for your Friday
film future Fredo
[Music]